We just are such lucky people that we get to eat this food
and celebrate these restaurants and what a better way
to kick off our week celebrating meat than with.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
Barbecue ribs.
Oh, please, thank you so much.
There are so many amazing barbecue places around the US,
and we couldn't possibly feature them all,
but we're going to try to cover the three bases,
with three different restaurants in three different cities.
But first, we need our taste-testing partner in crime,
Ross Matthews.
Well, hi there. Hi, fellow barbecutie.
(Ross giggling)
Um, all right, let's not forget the stakes.
Yeah, that's a meat pun, the stakes being the spot
with the most votes wins our Battle of the Bites trophy!
Yeah, oh, wow.
(grand music)
Isn't it wonderful?
Ross, are you a fan of barbecue?
I don't have a beef with it.
(Ross chuckling)
No, of course, I love barbecue.
Whenever I'm in any of these states,
I have to get the barbecue.
It's the best of the best, and they do it so differently,
so this is going to be quite the battle.
And now joining us for this taste test are three
of our VFFs: hello to Adrian, Emily, and Mable.
(audience applauding)
Hi, guys! Hi, guys!
Hi!
We're so excited to do this with you.
And of course our final vote in the competition
comes from our social media fans.
We put up a Twitter poll asking everyone at home to vote
for their favorite, and we'll count that as one vote
towards who becomes the winner at the end of this.
All right, let's get started.
Now, we each have three plates of ribs
with a signature side.
All right, I'm so excited.
Our first up is Kings Restaurant.
Please take a look.
Hello, my name is Joe Hargitt and I am the owner
of Kings Restaurant, here in Kinston, North Carolina.
The business started off in 1936
by a fellow named Frank King,
and he had a son named Wilbur Senior.
He brought his two brothers into the business
and hence we became Kings Brothers Barbecue.
Today, we're going to talk about our baby back pork ribs,
how tender they are, and we smoke 'em here in-house,
a Applewood smoke.
They're so tender, they fall off the bone
before they even get into the smoker.
We don't use any fancy rubs or anything like that.
We just use a really good, homemade
Eastern North Carolina barbecue sauce.
Last year we sold 39,000 pounds of baby back pork ribs.
Our featured side that we've decided to use
is collard greens.
It is a Southern staple, a family recipe that has been
in Kings Restaurant for almost 85 years.
We get our collard greens from a local farmer,
not 20 miles away.
We cook over 3,000 pounds of collard greens a week.
We supply restaurants all over Eastern North Carolina
with our collard greens.
So in this difficult time, when travel was restricted,
let pigs fly right into your house
and land on your taste buds.
(audience applauding)
(Drew laughing)
We welcome that.
Yes, please.
All right everybody, you ready?
Yeah.
Let's eat!
All right, let's go.
Mmm! Okay.
This is good.
That's good.
The smoke really goes through, like, your nasal passages.
It goes into your whole olfactory.
I didn't think it'd be that flavorful.
Yeah, that's incredible.
Okay.
All right, Adrian, you're a James Beard Award-winning
writer, food writer, you've had your fair share of ribs
from over 200 places.
I am so honored to ask you, what do you think of these?
Hey, it's so good to be with you.
So yeah, I like this.
This is really delicate, you know, tender.
I put some of the grilling sauce that I got on there,
so that added some flavor.
And then I love collard greens,
so I'm glad they threw this in the mix.
This is a very soulful touch, so (indistinct).
Have you tried these yet, the collard greens?
Okay, get in. This is so good.
Oh my gosh.
What is going on in this? It's perfect.
Well done.
Oh, thank you so much, Adrian.
Okay, we're moving on to our next contender
at Charles Vergos Rendezvous, check this out.
Hi, Drew. I'm Robert, Head Pitmaster at the Rendezvous.
And I'm Anna, one of the managers at the Rendezvous.
In the forties, ribs had been a staple
of backyard barbecues in Memphis neighborhoods,
but they weren't served on menus.
At that time, ribs were actually considered scrap meat,
and they were extremely cheap.
And for this reason, Charlie thought he'd try 'em out.
That's when he developed his own style
and what is now known as Memphis-style ribs.
To this day, we still cook the ribs the same way
he cooked them back then.
We cook our ribs in this here pit: 16 inches over a fire.
To preserve the tenderness though, we baste them
in a pickle juice, but once the ribs are done,
before we plate 'em to you, we baste them again
with another baste solution to give them to you
before we put the dry rub on them.
We also provide sauce on the side,
just in case you'd like them a little saucy.
The seasoning on the ribs you're about to eat
is what we've been told is the original dry rub,
and what ultimately makes our ribs.
And our side that you're going to taste
is a mustard, vinegar-based slaw.
It is our family's 100-year-old recipe.
People have enjoyed the Rendezvous restaurant
for seven decades.
We seat over 700 people at a time,
4,000 people on a busy night.
We catered Air Force One a few times,
the Rolling Stones have played in our dining room
and even Elvis have eaten Rendezvous.
We hope you guys enjoy this little taste
of our Memphis barbecue.
Wow, that history.
Air Force One, Elvis, and the Rolling Stones.
Are you ready, guys?
So ready. This is so different than the last one.
Ready?
Oh, wow.
Okay.
Oh, that'll wake you up.
Mmm.
Okay, and you can certainly taste all the spices
in that dry rub; even the texture's different, right?
Yeah, and it really has like a nice crust on it.
Emily, it's your family tradition
to have a rib fest every year.
What are your thoughts on these ribs?
This spice, it just completely permeates the rib
and the meat and it just tastes absolutely amazing.
It's not too overwhelming,
but it has just such a great flavor to it.
I love it.
Have you guys gone to town on this slaw yet?
I'm obsessed with this.
I haven't stopped eating the ribs yet.
Let me move over. I feel so.
Get ready.
Ooh!
I know, I know.
What's really great is how crunchy the slaw is, yeah.
Really good.
Emily, thank you so much for your permeating,
especially, word, that's one of my favorites.
My honor, please.
Now we've already tried ribs from Kings Restaurant
in North Carolina, from Charles Vergos from Tennessee,
and now we get to do Joe's Kansas City Bar-B-Que
from Kansas; check this out.
Hey Drew, hey Ross, Eric Tadda here,
with Joe's Kansas City Bar-B-Que in Kansas City.
Joe's Kansas City Bar-B-Que started in the nineties
when our owner, Jeff and Joy Stehney,
were on the championship barbecue circuit,
and they absolutely fell in love
with serving championship barbecue here in Kansas City.
Joe's KC has been a staple here in Kansas City
for almost 25 years.
And almost just as famous as our barbecue
is where we serve our barbecue, in a gas station.
Joe's has been fortunate to serve our barbecue
to President Obama and the staff on Air Force One.
We have two hometown customers in Jason Sudeikis
and Paul Rudd, and the great chef Anthony Bourdain
once said that Joe's KC Bar-B-Que
is one of the 13 places you must eat before you die.
This year alone, Joe's KC is going to sell and ship
172,000 slabs of ribs nationwide.
We think our ribs are unique because of how we cook them.
We cook them low and slow at 245 degrees for four hours
over Missouri white oak.
So Drew, Ross, we are super excited to be part of this day.
We also included some of our championship barbecue beans.
Got a little spice for your palate.
I think you're going to enjoy.
(audience applauding)
Okay, everybody, you ready? Let's eat.
Very different.
So different than the other two.
But, like that really beautiful,
kind of what you really think is like a barbecue sauce.
There's certainly layers in this one, yum.
You're absolutely right, Ross.
Mable, you were born and raised in the South,
and you consider yourself authority on barbecue ribs.
Will you please give us your thoughts?
Well, Drew, I have to tell you, this rib is good!
It's tangy, it's really easy to come off of the bone,
the meat is really tender.
And the sauce, the sauce is so amazing.
It's right on point, Drew.
It's really, really good.
I think you're absolutely right about that sauce, Mable.
They're all very different.
So different.
Okay, well, it's time to vote.
This is going to be really hard.
Before we do, we asked you all to vote on Twitter
to say who your favorite rib joint was
from all these extraordinary places.
And 61% of the vote was Joe's Bar-B-Que, Kansas City!
I can see why.
So that's one vote for Joe's Kansas City Bar-B-Que.
I love that they're in like that Shamrock gas station,
that is so cool, that makes you feel like such a foodie.
Okay, and now it's our turn.
All right, one at a time,
we're going to reveal our favorite.
So kick us off, Adrian.
(victorious music)
Wow, Joe's Kansas City.
I really, really trust your palate.
Okay, beautiful Emily, what is your vote?
Joe's was phenomenal, I agree,
but I have to go with Kings.
(victorious music)
(audience applauding)
Okay, stunning, smart Mable, what is your vote?
Kansas City, of course. Kansas City, here I come.
(Drew squealing)
All right, oh my gosh, that's three for Joe's.
Ross, it's your turn.
Okay, listen, I loved each one of these.
I don't have a bone to pick with any of them,
but one of them has to win
and I have to say it was the tenderness
and the side dish of collard greens
that put Kings Restaurant over the road for me.
It was so good.
I have to do Kings, too.
I was really not expecting how much flavor
would come out of those ribs
and I can't stop eating those collard greens.
You're absolutely right.
And I love the sauce, so, oh my gosh, it's a tie!
So, guess what, both of those restaurants
are each getting a trophy!
(audience applauding)
Oh, the more, the merrier! I love that.
And if you want to do your own taste test at home,
all of these restaurants can be found on none other
than Goldbelly, heaven on earth, Goldbelly.
That should be their motto.
Congrats to all three restaurants.
Thank you so much for honoring us by participating in this.
And I really want to thank our VFFs,
Adrian, Emily, and Mable.
Thank you so much for hanging out with us today.
(upbeat music)